common issue that fathers encounter wife
is pregnant future dad to be 9 months
deep dad doesn't feel like he cares
about child dad doesn't have any change
in paternal Instinct dad doesn't have
any bond develops after birth for dads
it develops um and there's plenty of
evidence but they feel guilt and shame
and I remember where I sat in Austin
with this room 100 millionaire 100
millionaire billionaire millionaire
millionaire 100 millionaire and it was
one of these you know guys if anyone's
got anything that they you know they
wanted a bit of advice on we've got a
room of people that are pretty capable
in here and you can say what you want
this was like wife's 8 months pregnant
don't think I'm going to love the kid
what do I do and dude sat across from
him was like give it 6 months after the
birth Everything Will Change but that
fear and the guilt and the shame and can
I tell my partner does this mean I don't
love my partner does this mean I'm going
to be a terrible father all of these
things from that episode I haven't had
so many tags and messages from guys in a
really long time I thought I was broken
I thought I was defective oh I am going
through this right now my wife is X
months pregnant or the child is 3 months
old and I'm like I just feel nothing for
this kid and it and it just takes longer
for me